what's up guys uh happy afternoon to you
and happy morning and everything and um
i am here and i am uh just wanted to
prove through some of these comments
and see what y'all had on me uh this is
from switch and bait
the new king and the sting and uh
so here's the image right here so you
can see that first image of me bang
so you know what i look like in it
there you go and
uh read some of these theo looks like a
tennis coach for
david bowie uh that's pretty good
that's pretty good dude i get that about
a five or six
or five um
actually i get that about a seven man
that's better i'm sorry i was in a bad
mood a second ago
brendan looks like he's trying to
overthrow management at a gays only
chuck e cheese
give that a tad oh
brennan looks like he fixes the ticket
machine at chuck e cheese he does look
like that
so that's great that's phenomenal
um
brandon
first of all that last one was n8 credit
cred
create nate create
before that it was saul sandoval and uh
colton shriver
on that 565. um
this one brendan looks like his favorite
pastime rhymes with
gay but sex
and that is a tan hilarious that's her
name and that is uh the boosack the
busan
um oh damn this
is good
man you're making me get the giggle out
man keith haywood said
brendan looks like he owns a jimmy
john's franchise
but but doesn't have it open for the
public
oh damn that is
so perfect man man i wish i was smart as
that guy
um let me see
brendan looks like the new guy starting
at autozone from prasanth t
uh he does and that's a good that's a
good choice
it didn't make me laugh but that doesn't
mean it's not funny man it just
you know i already read a couple and
i've already laughed a few times so i
might not have as much laughs at me as
i usually do uh
let me see theo looks like he hangs out
at the beach volleyball court so we can
sell fake performance-enhancing pills
um that almost made me laugh he rose
that almost made me laugh
god damn
brendan looks like he uses the weekends
for ex
experimenting with guys
rob c that made me laugh um
brennan looks like the
brandon looks like the bouncer at a papa
john's and that's from russell simmons
damn
and i think he had rape charges against
him but
good to see that he is uh back and
living his life and everything i heard
he did a yoga center somewhere and was
doing some lead stuff out there but um
let me see
theo looks like his glasses and nose are
a combo item you order on amazon
that uh that's good
that's really really good and that's
true that's one of the reasons why i
feel tough about wearing glasses because
my nose already looks fake
and that's from blondie man be a lot be
a loney baloney
um brendon damn
man some kings out here devin harrington
brendan looks like he's all five
guys so that is so hard
um theo looks like toucan sam's straight
cousin trying to buy coke
at liz fair uh vehicle city comedy
didn't make me laugh but
i did like it i did like it
uh theo looks like a background dancer
for pitbull
that's pretty good chris brezzick
uh theo looks like he gets handed a
honeydew list
writes feminism on it and hands it back
and that would that's semi-realistic
um
i gotta get back to work man but uh
brendan this from tony f who obviously
is trying to be anonymous but giving us
clues
uh brennan looks like the perfect poster
boy for mr clean's new line of citrus
enemas and i am
dead uh
here's one the daddy vato theo looks
like he rents out
bouncy castles and lived in one for a
bit
so that's pretty fire got my cat shirt
on today man i'm feeling excited i'm
feeling hopeful
um so yeah just wanted to chime in a
little bit and hit you guys with that
man thank you guys for all the great
comments man um you know
this is uh the ship made me laugh dude
to really know when so
praise god baby gang hope you enjoyed
that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one